Hi, Susan.
Welcome to traveler. Thank you for coming.
Thank you. How was the camp here going?
It's going very well. Very,
very busy. I'm all over the country at the moment.
So last week I was in Kilkenny and we went to.
I was in Limerick this morning,
and it's just. It's crazy at the moment,
but it's great. I'm meeting loads of people
and hearing about loads of different issues.
Good. And Susan,
when you're elected to the European Parliament,
can you give us three priorities that you're gonna focus on?
Absolutely. So one of the most important issues,
obviously, at the moment is housing in Ireland.
So one of my main goals
would be to create an action plan for affordable housing in Ireland.
There's loads of funding streams within the EU at the moment
that aren't being utilized for affordable housing and social housing,
and we could be using those funding streams which were not.
So that would be a very important priority for me.
Um, another one would be disability rights.
I am a big campaigner for disability rights in Ireland,
and I've been a disability advocate for years.
And I feel like there's a lot more that could be done at an EU level,
uh, for people with disabilities through creating, uh,
laws at an EU level
to make sure that people with disabilities across the union, um,
are treated equally and allowed to live fully inclusive lives.
And then thirdly,
I would be Supporting small to medium sized businesses.
I think at the moment
the cost of living crisis is making things extremely hard
for employers and businesses
and also for employees.
So I think there's a lot more we could be doing at an EU level
to get grants and also low interest loans and funding for businesses.
That's brilliant. Best luck with your campaign, Susan.
Thank you. And if you haven't followed Susan on social media yet,
I'll put all the links here in the bottom.